I will switch here from GVHD to conditioning regimen.
So this is...
Thank you.
All right, so I will talk about the use of the next-generation radiominal therapy
using the alpha-ammeter as part of the conditioning regimen
for a patient with high-risk leukemia.
I have no disclosure for this one.
So we all know that the main problem in conditioning regimen
is still the trade-off between the toxicity and relapse.
Reduced-intensity conditioning could help to reduce significantly
the treatment-related mortality from 25% to about 10%,
but it comes at the price of significantly higher risk
of the relapse.
So we know for decades that radiation works.
This is a landmark randomized trial from Fred Hutch
almost three decades ago showing us very clearly here
the dose effect of radiation to relapse rates of patients with ALL.
So higher-dose TBI could significantly decrease the relapse
from 35% to 12%, but again, the benefit is offset
by higher-dose TBI.
So we know for decades that radiation works.
So higher-dose TBI could significantly decrease the relapse from 35% to 12%,
but again, the benefit is offset by higher-dose TBI.
There's one way to enhance the anti-tumor efficacy
and reduce the toxicity of radiation is to target the radiation
to the site of the malignancy and spare the normal tissues.
So the RIT concept pioneered by the researchers at Fred Hutch.
So in RIT, we use a monoclonal antibody as a kind of biological vehicle
conjugated with radiation isotope to deliver radiation.
So in RIT, we use a monoclonal antibody as a kind of biological vehicle conjugated with radiation
to the site of the disease, like bone marrow spleen,
and with very minimized toxicity to the surrounding tissue.
So two key elements of RIT, the target antigen for patient with he malignancy AML,
the CD45, have been used very commonly because of its broad expression on hematopoietic cells
and very limited expression on the non-hematopoietic cells, and the other component is,
the radiation isotope.
So the first generation RIT, you know, we use the beta particles like iodide-131 and yttrium-90
because of, you know, it varies based on the availability,
the experience for their critical use, together with the radiolabeling technology.
Okay.
So the beta-emitter platform, like IOMAP, have been shown yesterday that the feasibility
and the ability to scale across the center, however, for the beta particles, they have
relatively long path length and also lower radiation deposition.
So this allows the post-fire effects, but it also leads to the higher radiation exposure
to the surrounding tissue.
On the other hand, the beta particles have very different physical properties.
They have significantly shorter path length and higher linear energy transfer.
So that instead of having diffuse radiation, we now would have very highly precise and
potent radiation to deliver to the site of the malignancy while minimizing the exposure
of the surrounding tissues.
So this is the pre-clinical murine models.
We can see that acetine-211 label with the anti-CD45 show the dose effect bone marrow
suppression very clearly here.
So at a lower dose, the 10-microcurie, we can see, you know, transient bone marrow suppression
with hypocellularity about 24, 48 hours, and then after that, at one week, the marrow recovery,
it will recover.
When the dose increased to 20 microcurie, we can observe deeper cytopenia later about
two weeks and then recovery about three weeks.
When the dose gets higher to 50 microcurie, so this transition to really irreversible
myeloblation and really lethal cytopenia.
So this is very important, and this is, you know, provides a very strong rationale for
clinical translation, this to the transplant conditioning.
So that's led to our first in-human trial at Fred Hutch when we combined the acetine
label with CD45 monoclonal antibody with our backbone flu low-dose TBI conditioning regimen
for patient-received matched donors.
So this study design with the two-stage approach, a stage one dose fighting to identify the
maximum tolerated dose and the expansion cohort in stage two, so we enrolled 45 patients so
far.
This is the first 20 patients with excellent follow-up time.
This is the patient with, you know, very extensive history of the treatment before, including
three patients with prior allo transplant.
So this is the table to show you in more details of the patient characteristics with the pre-transplant
bone marrow blast.
Fifty percent of those patients had active disease at time of transplant with the blast
ranging up to 80, 85 percent in the bone marrow.
The other 50 percent.
So this is the patient who was in CR but actually more than half of them had MRD at the time
of the transplant.
So the PK study showing you here the clearance kinetics of the isotope and as you can see
that they decrease rapidly and about 40 hours after the infusion, they pretty much clear
out from the blood.
So despite the fact that we deliver significantly higher radiation to the bone marrow but the
engraftment preserved, you know, with neutrophil and platelet engraftment pretty much as expected
in the patient.
So we can see that the patient is very well established.
We can see that the patient is very well established.
my team. Thank you for your attention.